last night I got contacted by the braska
of Baylor Georgia Memphis do Ohio state
Alabama UConn and Pittsburgh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is terras part we had the MVP a
camp with jr. about to get lit in gonna
be show me a great 7 soon it right now
when I was not at any of those I
definitely sees it I never had the
vision of you know being Who I am now
you know that's why every day I was
getting the gym working because when I
was younger I never thought this would
ever happen to me I was playing bass
with the fun back home in Boston now we
need one of the best teams in New
England we didn't lose the game for two
years straight and then 5th grade we
actually went out to Atlantic City to
play guys will again some more
competition and we lost the team
takeover by I think 35 plus that's when
I really cried sacked and I said you
know I want to take this serious
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
College voted to be at my game I try not
to pay attention to it too much you know
cuz they're right there and then
obviously looking at my every move so I
just try to be on my best behavior I
felt a lot of pressure when I was like
first going through this stuff but now
that I've been playing in front of them
a lot more it's just more than just you
know just playing like I just have fun
is the game that I love and I've been
playing since I was in fifth grade so I
just wanna show that I'm a great player
obviously versatile and have skills like
you know next level I got a robot in
this college oh yo brother is this my
stuff so I just send that back to that
no basketball of course is a bigger part
in our lives but you know I stuff that's
off the court you know we're gonna be 18
19 years old like life gets real so you
know learning the stuff off the court
from them you got those guys that's
already been in the NBA or guys I've
been through it it's just you know it's
my floor and it helps us you know by not
rushing you came off the pick you did
what you had to do but why you rushed it
don't rush it when you go off the screen
that's Russia pull that thing back okay
he's come off there's food spray hey
we're Ricky Davis being homie as hard as
he is it just shows me that you know
I've I have a chance definitely expects
a lot out of me like he's been in 98 you
know we haven't given our tips it's not
like that trying to be helpful is it's
great you know nowadays two generations
has changed so you know it can't be all
crazy and hard like I grew up back in
the day you know coaches is just riding
me the whole practice so you know you
hit him hear him there get them with
some good teaching points and and you
know just watch his growth you see how
you got that steel that's the energy
right there
the festival in this moment but you got
a leaf by example they following you
they say what Tara faves Landy he's
shootin all the shots
what'd you tell you know you should be
amazing I think Ricky doesn't wanted me
to play defense alot so I think I'm
gonna just add that to my game really
because if I don't play defense he gonna
yell at me a million times so just
playing both sides in court you know
whose green gain stands and stuff I
thought I'd leave to run ons healer just
getting layups or you know finding
somebody else with easy Bucky so like 2
to 3 stairs or you know defensive stops
to get a defensive rebound he's one of
the best players in the camp so he has
to always be ready always be a hundred
percent 120% and that's what the coach
is looking for
[Music]
a camp environment I feel like it is
better to showcase your skills
especially with me trying to be a point
guard I want to bring the ball look como
screens and stuff like that find out the
guys I think I can play the role and he
gave me the ROG I think I definitely do
it you know I think I should pass it I
scored I did I could show a lot of
people that I would play definitely like
one two or three
[Music]
[Music]
walking out of MVPA I think everybody
could say that they learned something
you know just to take with them with
this Homer coming up I think you know
just trying to work on my every part of
my game you know jump shot I handle
everything I can do on the court I was
gonna read it for me so I try to work on
everything this Homer at the Cape
I must be working out a lot getting
ready for peach in July stuff but after
that I just be working on stuff like
that probably getting ready for Steph
Curry camp and Cha to get into skills as
much luck
main goal is to make it to the MBA so
Michael Porter and Inter a young more
like guys like Collin Sexton those guys
I always looked up to them was like I
want to be like them one day I top and
prospect in the country I am now
scholarly I'm gonna get the MBA I just
want to take care of everybody that's
been through this journey
[Music]
what's up you guys it's Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for more video content